My name is Yoshua Bengio.
I am a professor at University of Montréal,
and the Scientific Director and Founder of Mila.
I had this crazy dream that we could turn
the small critical mass of the time of researchers
in deep-learning and reinforcement
learning in Montreal into something big
that would have an impact on society,
and that would make Montreal a central hotbed
of AI in the world.
And I tried to convince people to help us build
that dream, and it worked, and here we are.
Mila is a large community.
Initially, the focus was really
deep-learning and reinforcement learning,
and it's still the main strength,
but it has broadened, and we can now say
Mila is a machine learning hothouse
covering the state-of-the-art in machine-learning.
And of course machine-learning is
what's driving the progress in AI these days.
Mila has grown at an incredible rate.
A decade ago, it was a handful of professors,
30 students;
and now we're talking about almost
40 resident professors
and almost as many associate members,
and… whatever, 600 students or something.
When we created Mila, we decided that of course
fundamental progress
in the science of AI was our number one mission,
that we would of course train
the next generation of researchers
and practitioners of AI,
but we decided that it was important to think
about the social impact of our work.
We can really be proud today
of the progress we've made in AI.
If we compare the state-of-the-art systems
that we have today with those we had ten years
or twenty years or thirty years ago, it's amazing.
That's why these systems
are being deployed in society.
But at the same time, if we compare these
state-of-the-art systems to what humans can do,
what a two-year-old can do, what a cat can do,
we still have a lot of progress to make.
So, I'm getting inspiration from neuroscience,
cognitive science, but also mathematics,
like causality and statistics, to hopefully
build the next generation of AI systems.
AI is becoming a tool in the hands of scientists,
engineers, medical researchers,
all across society, in the industry…
It's hard to say where the progress will be
the most significant in the coming years.
But clearly, in places where we have
or will have data, it's going to go faster.
Because AI needs large quantities
of data to understand the material,
understand the domain that we want to apply it to.
I'm sure that the impact of AI
in the next ten years will be amazing.
Just like we have been amazed
by the progress in the last ten years.
And finally, personally I'm super excited
about the potential research advances
that I see in front of us that could
change the game scientifically
and also in terms of society.
But, you know, that's why researchers are
so motivated by their work,
it's because they see something
and they want to go there.